hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 5 video all about
dr. light and pushing into a big
confrontation with it zoom so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet I'm also starting a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll just I'll remind everyone
when I post my arrow video and Supergirl
later in the week so here we go we've
met a couple really big characters so
I'll explain those as we get through
Easter eggs and top five WTF there were
some like really awesome questions that
were raised a big pot reveals about
what's going on with zoom so this gonna
be really exciting and this is a
two-parter the next episode like part
two of this storyline is called enter
zoom data later next week so just hold
your breath for like the next seven days
and you should be good but starting with
top 5 WTF meet earth to Harrison wells
who's kind of like an evil Steve Jobs
Elon Musk Lex Luthor from Batman vs
Superman that's actually the same
characterization they're using to
describe Lex Luthor and Batman vs
Superman he's kind of like evil Mark
Zuckerberg evil Elon Musk when he says
he's a genius inventor and then shows
off his watch all I could think about
was the Apple watch as like maybe
they're kind of saying there's something
sinister going on with apples watch but
it's a complex system for tracking
metahumans so it sounds like even before
zoom has captured his daughter in the
past
Harrison wells of earth 2 really does
not like metahumans but they had the
same type of dark matter explosion that
created metahumans but 11 hours prior to
that as Jay Garrick explains there was
another dark matter incident below STAR
Labs
so zoom appeared before like the big
metahuman blast he like he preceded it
so some experiment that Harrison wells
of earth 2 was working on led to the
creation of zoom but we really just got
a tease like it raises more questions
than it answered it's like all these
plot reveals that they gave and when
Harrison wells is doing his speech there
in the beginning but you know before Jay
Garrick shows up he talks about
metahumans being able to do a bunch of
different things he's basically
describing all the people in Justice
Society Jay Garrick was a big Justice
Society member so I think most of the
Easter eggs for his character will be
relative to that versus Justice League
which Barry Allen was part of but on to
number 4 meet Jesse quick who is earth -
Harrison wells daughter now she is a
speedster in the comic books don't know
if she's going to get Speed Force powers
in the TV
show it might just be a change from the
character but it's a huge easter egg and
it's so much fun to see on the show and
I was so happy at the end of the episode
when she was still alive because it
seemed like Harrison wells was really
after metahumans like he really wanted
to kill all these metahumans take them
down and it could have been because one
of them either killed his wife or his
daughter and now we know that zoom has
captured his daughter we still don't
know what happened to his wife though so
hopefully episode 6 being the enter zoom
episode like the part 2 of this we'll
find out what's going on with Jessie
quick like why zoom captured her it
seems like zoom hates Harrison wells for
some reason otherwise he would probably
just kill his daughter he probably
wouldn't keep her captive so he must
need him for something in a Jay Garrick
is very pure of heart so if he doesn't
trust Harrison wells says that he has
secrets there's definitely something
that we don't know about him yet on to
number three though meet dr. light of
earth to Linda Park this is the greatest
thing ever you can see the exact moment
that Barry poops his pants like oh hey
hey it's my ex-girlfriend who is a
metahuman and a villain the really
important thing with her character I
think is establishing that she's not a
psychopath like some of the other
metahumans we've run into she's not like
sand demon she's only going after flash
because she's more afraid of zoom
although although all the other
metahumans are afraid of zoom
she just wants to get out of town she's
like please just let me go just let me
take the money get out of here but
here's where things get a little bit
more complicated she says that she needs
to kill earth 1 Linda Park her
doppelganger in order to get free of
zoom why is that so important like what
does the doppelganger have to do a zoom
but the interesting thing is is that
zoom knew about Barry's relationship
with earth 1 Linda Park presumably
without coming to earth 1 unless he was
secretly scoping Barry out without Barry
knowing about it unless he's an evil
version of Barry and has like some weird
Cisco type connection to him like he can
sense what Barry has done in the past he
might be from the future there's really
like fewer and fewer possibilities now
so if you're thinking that this is earth
to Barry look the chances just slowly
rose a little bit I mean it's not a
guarantee but think about it this way if
Harrison wells knows that he created
zoom why hasn't he said anything about
who he thinks zoom is Jay Garrick
finally started to have that
conversation with Caitlin like what's
different about your earth like tell me
more about it like who's there who's
different well there's this place
called Atlantis that I really like that
was my favorite thing ever one of my
best friends lives there so of course on
my number two WTF moment meet Jay
Garrick's best friend Arthur curry aka
Aquaman Atlantis is above ground this is
this is complete confirmation of Aquaman
by the way on earth - they're just
they're just having a little bit of fun
weaking at us by not saying his name the
reason I think the TV show is able to do
this is because they're probably not
going to show him on screen like it's
it's totally okay for them to reference
him but there's only been two episodes
of Supergirl so far and they've
name-dropped Superman a couple times but
also in the same vein we finally meet
Hawkgirl up close and personal Cisco of
course and grand fashion face palms
right in front of her like oh hey you're
asking me out how wonderful I can't wait
to see what Hawkman says about this when
he sees them together on a date and
remember episode 8 is the Vandal Savage
episode we're getting really close to
that so we'll actually be meeting
Hawkman very soon and just to be clear
she does not know that she is Hawkgirl
she only knows the first self as Kendra
Saunders Hawkman knows all about their
history he's gonna be the one to explain
it to her but finally out of my number
one WTF moment Barry is going to take
zoom head-on in a full-blown Empire
Strikes Back episode next week does that
mean that he's going to get his hand
chopped off I wonder just listen to Yoda
you're not ready for a confrontation
with Vader yet I do like the idea that
Jay Garrick is Barry Zeo to this season
and I know it seems like he's hit the
road but I totally think he's gonna be
back but the real question now is is
what happened beneath STAR Labs of Earth
- they created zoom and what - Harrison
wells and Dark Matter have to do with it
because they said there was a Dark
Matter incident and I mean there could
be a number of things happening beneath
STAR Labs
but remember beneath our STAR Labs they
built that portal that's that's where
the event horizon was so whatever the
key to zoom is it all started with
something that Harrison wells of earth 2
was doing something he was trying to
create in it might have something to do
with the negative Speed Force but I
still like the idea that zoom is like
the negative reverse or like some evil
version of a character that we already
know my question for you guys though is
do you think that Harrison wells of
Earth 2 knows who zoom is and just isn't
telling or do you think that he has a
lot of suspicions like what what is it
that he was doing that created zoom why
is he responsible for that I know a lot
of people also want to think that it
might be
we're klaris the reverse-flash from the
Jay Garrick era and the comics the
Golden Age reverse-flash but because the
show hasn't introduced another character
like that yet I still think that it's
someone that we've seen already and if
it were ever éclairs that'd have to be a
completely new character but I feel like
the show's doing better than ever like
you know when when the possibilities of
zoom corrode despite the fact that they
reveal a lot about his backstory it says
a lot about the writing just that I tend
to find stories that are harder to
figure out to be more rewarding
ultimately it's a lot more fun to
rewatch when you don't figure everything
out during episode 1 and I know I
haven't said a lot about the
relationship comedy stuff that was going
on in the episode like Barry Patti iris
but I do like what they're doing with
Barry and iris this year like iris for
instance amazing with the gun that we
learned out like so she's actually she's
getting really interesting story stuff
that has nothing to do with her
relationship status and she's the one
that encourages Barry to go out with
Patti like they'll always be best
friends like iris will always be Barry's
best friend regardless of their feelings
for each other and the literal blind
date was kind of funny I think we'll see
more of that kind of stuff as the
episodes get on but I just I like the
idea of Patti helping Barry more than
Barry helps Patti I think they just want
to present her as someone who is not a
damsel to be rescued at all times which
which i think is great of all the female
characters but hands-down the best quote
in the episode like the best line of
dialogue was when Caitlin snow said I
don't think that any one of us would
turn evil if we suddenly got powers who
fell out of their chair after she said
that and more interesting than Harrison
wells outing Cisco to the group as a
metahuman I think is the fact that his
watch didn't like fly off the scale as
he passed by Caitlin like maybe the
watch has to be really close to them you
know maybe earth to Caitlin is going to
be killer frost all I know is that the
watch did not go off when he passed by
Caitlin of earth 1 and I think that
that's important but I'll caution you
guys to listen really carefully when
earth - Harrison wells is speaking he
speaks really fast and he had so many
Easter eggs in this episode just talking
about Justice Society members talking
about dark matter like talking about the
origins of zoom so whenever he's
speaking in scenes just like listen
really carefully you could accidentally
skip like really big Harrison wells
reveals and remember he's not evil he's
just a super big who is trying
to save his daughter we know now so in
newse they're also supposed to be
revealing the identity of lash on agents
of shield and I'm still finishing my
Gotham video so what's gonna happen next
is I'll finish up Gotham post that then
I'll post agents of shield and then I'll
post like you know whatever is left over
so don't worry all those videos will
post in my Supergirl video will post on
Thursday for sure there's so much
awesome DC TV on right now what why you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for the Warcraft teaser
they posted like a short teaser the full
trailer is going to come on Friday and
you can click here for last week's
episode of the flash thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight